[Music]
all right let's go to
mike in green bay hey mike what's up man
hey dr dolani thanks for uh taking my
call here you got man what's up
my in-laws are into online conspiracy
theories
and my wife had a hey i just i just lost
you come back one more time
your in-laws are into online conspiracy
theories
yes okay tell me about it
um i love those yeah it's
it's kind of everything it's the
election it's vaccines it's monetary
system
child sex trafficking everything all in
one
my wife had a boundary conversation with
them that went
very poorly okay and we kind of patch it
up a little bit but it's extremely
awkward talking to them my wife is
struggling because she doesn't
know who to talk to without making her
parents sound crazy
and uh you know we're trying to figure
out how to move forward with the
relationship
how did the boundary conversation go
like i don't
i don't want you all to talk about this
stuff anymore with me i'm tired of
hearing it like what
what how did it go yeah um
they'd started emailing stuff out to us
an extended family
um and usually what they emailed wasn't
terrible but the problem was the next
video
claimed that everybody was backside was
gonna die and they sent
it to people who were vaccinated hey
here's the thing that's true about that
everyone who got got vaccinated will
eventually die that's super true
i don't know what your problem is mike
but listen
everybody who got a vaccine is one day
gonna be dead i think there was a two
years claim in there that was the
problem
oh okay well fair enough all right um
so it was basically we don't want you to
talk to us about this
we don't find these sources credible if
you want to send something it's got to
be credible
and don't talk to our kids or we're not
going to you know this will be a deal
breaker
yep and so they took it as an attack on
their beliefs which it
i guess kind of was yeah and plus i
think just
freaked out about uh essentially saying
you're not gonna see your grandkids if
you don't stop
and so it went awkward
they said you're attacking our beliefs
and
so you guys put up a boundary and then
they crashed into it
and then what happened to that boundary
did you all say okay you can email us
or do they say okay we'll quit um
i'd say it went way more than awkward it
went horrible but they have respected
the boundaries
okay it's just now it's extremely
awkward to interact with them because
you really can't
share much of your life because of the
beliefs are kind of intertwined in
everything so you can't talk about
what's happening without a risk of
knocking into that
oh so you can't talk about like what's
going on in the world like i guess you
can't talk about health or politics or
medicine or anything because y'all are
such odds
yes okay and so how can i help
i guess we're trying to figure out do we
just keep moving forward i mean
it's kind of like there's an elephant in
the room do we need to address it or we
move forward
plus any advice on how my wife can get
help
because she really feels like she
doesn't have any anybody to talk to
because her parents are good people of
course
and she doesn't want to bash them in
front of friends or
yeah yeah so that that doesn't help
anybody um okay so let me back out a
little bit
there was a remarkable article a while
ago we'll link to it in the show notes
from peter etia he's one of the most
brilliant minds on planet earth the guy
who i
have a lot of respect for um
he wrote um he's a statistician and a
medical doctor a longevity guy
but he wrote an awesome article on
conspiracy theories
and he had a couple of things in there
that
gave me some um
more empathy than i've ever had and so
he talked about these are a lot of big
words but
talks about um some of the biases and
fallacies that attract people to
conspiracy theories
like selection bias and confirmation
bias in group bias and false cause of
black and white fallacies and appeals to
emotion bandwagon
ambiguity except all the stuff right
burden of proof right all that kind of
stuff
um but then he goes on to say that often
conspiracy theories may be wired into us
for
survival purposes and so here here's
where he goes with that
a let's pretend ten thousand years ago
we're walking in the jungle
and a splash occurs next to us
more than likely that was a branch
falling from a tree
it was a rock it was filled any number
of things
but if we didn't jump and run
that small chance that was an alligator
we're dead it's over
and so there's a part of us that may be
hardwired
to see any sort of as this could kill me
right any sort of glitch in the matrix
any sort of big splash a loud noise
we are better off running and hiding and
pointing
because that keeps us alive it makes us
insane
but it keeps us alive right so he says
that it's far more likely that it's
nothing but the price to pay for being
wrong can change our actions
even if the statistics are in our favor
right
so at the end of the day i think there's
two things about the conspiracy
and i'll tell you it's a sport for me i
think they're hilarious and awesome
like i but here's the thing i don't
believe them
but they are super fun for me i do have
several friends that
not aren't all in they are a thousand
percent in
in the most hilarious ways
i got co-workers here who are dude it is
the most fun to have conversations
i feel like i'm on another planet it's
amazing and
um here's what i think it's about number
one i think it's about control
it is really hard for us to step back
and swallow the fact that a
volcano may erupt and just kill us all
it may be really hard for us to swallow
the fact that
and somebody on the other side of the
count on outside the world ate something
and it spun up a virus or even scarier
that there was a lab working on
something
and it accidentally got on a couple of
guys and they just went to the store
and then the whole world shut down that
is so
terrifying because that proves to us we
don't control
anything and so the only thing we can do
is double down on
oh no this is a giant plot by people who
know what they're doing to kill us all
does that make sense that's how i have
i can't live in a world where lee harvey
oswald just some oddball climbed up in
the top
of a library and shot the president i
can't live in a world where a guy's that
good of a marksman
where all i have to live in a world
where there's this massive
huge conspiracy that covered all that up
because if that can happen
the world we are spinning on is on a
razor's edge at all times
right um this happened at the capitol um
and on the january sixth thing when the
when those guys try to take over the
capital now i don't want to get in the
politics of all that
but what what blew my mind was i always
had this idea and i don't know what it
looked like but
that if you ever just tried to storm the
u.s capitol there was like lasers built
into the ground that just
zapped everybody i had i don't know what
i was thinking but i didn't know you
could do that
right i didn't know a group of people
could just run across the lawn and
climb the walls of the capitol i just
thought that like navy seals would fall
out of the clouds and
right and so either i have to believe
one of two things
oh crap that can happen like a group of
people could just get on the white house
lawn in charge
or that it was this big thing and that
there was you know all these things were
shut down and we had to does that make
sense
so living in a conspiracy world is
actually a safer world sometimes because
it it adds order to a potentially really
chaotic existence
and here's the second thing that is also
on top of that
is that when we don't sleep
and we stay glued to these screens and
we are anxious and anxious and anxious
anxiety makes us meaning making machines
it spins us up and we get obsessed with
trying to connect dots almost like a
beautiful mind so we get to these
these feelings that we're having our
bodies alarms that are set off
and man we have all been so exhausted
and
frustrated and angry and scared over the
last year and it's just given me some
some real compassion for folks and dude
i've got them in my life
i've got family members i've got
co-workers i know exactly what you're
dealing with
so here's the good news and the bad news
i'll give you the bad news first you
guys laid down a boundary and it's up to
y'all to hold it
and the promise of boundaries is that it
keeps you all safe it does not mean it
keeps you comfortable
it doesn't mean that it keeps you
friction free
and that's hard right
yep the other side of the good news is
y'all laid a boundary down and i'm proud
of you guys
what i think would be bold and brave if
they would do it and this is
the rare person that can do this would
be if you and or your wife
circled back and said hey there's
attention now
we just said we don't talk about this
stuff anymore and now i feel like we
can't talk about anything
and um i don't want to lose y'all's
relationship and at the same time these
things are hard for us to swallow
um how's the last month for y'all been
and
listen to them and let them speak it out
loud does that make sense
not everybody can do that i know
a lot of times um when boundaries get
put up people smash their heads up
against them they get angry they get
mad they kick and scream and all of a
sudden they think oh gosh someone
precious who i love is on the other side
of that boundary and i'm not going to
lose that
i may be crazy but i've seen that in my
own family i've seen that in my own
personal relationships that may be too
soon for you guys
um and you guys have to make peace with
it may just not happen
it may not happen i am interested in
this when you guys said hey we're not
going to have you talk to our kids about
this crap we're not going to talk about
this stuff
um what did they say you don't love your
children
how dare you like what was their
response
um no they actually they um
they agreed to that they respected it
they didn't uh
they didn't argue about that too much um
so what where's the awkwardness coming
from
is it now coming from you guys you all
laid down the law and you won
and now you guys don't know what to talk
about yes
so are there things you want to talk to
them about
well i mean the struggle is we have
public-facing jobs where you have to
take over seriously we can't talk about
that
you can't talk about much work you
pretty much
you're down to talking about the weather
and
it's just like what do you interact with
them a lot
uh yeah we used to daily
i mean they live a lot quite a ways away
but we used to talk them daily
it's less frequent now and uh we used to
have a very close relationship with them
and i think that's probably the
loss there is hard yes i agree with that
so here's
two things i'm gonna throw out there man
you may roll your eyes and say this is
so cheesy
you can use me as the scapegoat just say
dude i've
we've got some knucklehead and he made
this recommendation i'd love it if y'all
would do this with us
they get to pick a book and you all get
to pick a book
and just say hey we want to read this
together y'all pick and we'll pick
um you all are obviously wise and smart
you raised a really
smart and beautiful wonderful daughter
and
we want to start like a little family
nerd book club
that may be so cheesy and they may roll
their eyes they may be all in
and it becomes a place for y'all to
discuss things
and it doesn't it can be fiction it
doesn't have to be about anything
dramatic the other thing is man we had
some of the funniest most hilarious time
not talking about stuff with my parents
um
especially during covenant we couldn't
visit they couldn't visit was playing
games on zoom they were a riot
playing charades on zoom playing card
game man it turned into some of the most
fun
um even setting up you know i imagine
you guys could set up two checkerboards
with the kids
whatever that looks like but see if
y'all can begin to do things together
maybe go visit with them and go fishing
spend some money that y'all probably
wouldn't
hadn't planned on spending go if you do
some things like that that y'all can get
together
i think that would be really remarkable
and instead of focusing on
talking about stuff issues man try to
get back into relational stuff
play games read stuff together
watch a movie with your wife and they
can watch it y'all talk about it
find common ground that is not about
those things
it's gonna be harder because you have
these default things politics
religion weather repeat and now you have
a chance to expand that portfolio things
you'll talk about
broaden this relationship heal it a
little bit then y'all get to decide you
want to keep your boundaries
they get to decide if they want to keep
your boundaries i'm proud of y'all i'm
proud of them
sounds like everybody said whoa
relationship's the most important thing
here
and now the balls and y'alls court to
come up with some new deeper ways to
connect with one another
right so thank you so much for that call
mike um i know that's hard dude i know
that's hard
and i know families all over the country
are dealing with that get creative and
preserve those relationships wherever
possible